speaking of excited we're very excited
about our next guest the award-winning
producer model and transgender rights
Advocate Gina racero Gina immigrated to
the U.S from the Philippines when she
was a teenager and Rose to the top of
the New York City modeling world for
nine years she kept her transgender
identity a secret however not even her
modeling agent knew she had been
assigned mail at Birth then in 2014 she
came out publicly in a TED Talk take a
listen from that
I was assigned boy at Birth based on the
appearance of my genitalia
I remember when I was five years old in
the Philippines walking around our house
I would always wear this t-shirt in my
head
and my mom asked me how come you always
wear that t-shirt in your head said Mom
this is my hair I'm a girl
I knew then how to self-identify
Gina resero's new Memoir horse Barbie is
out today and she joins us now Gina
thank you very much for being here we
have so much to talk to you about
including the title of the book horse
Barbie that's an unusual one there's so
many lines in the book I love like I
learned to be Trans in the Catholic
Church yes but first let's start with
that Ted talk because that was your big
coming out moment you were so poised on
stage but I got to imagine inside you're
feeling something different what was
that like you know people have asked me
that about
um what was that moment certainly I
think I got at that point after being
living you know stealth for eight years
when I decided that I'm going to do this
in the biggest stages possible I was
just so ready that my sense of purpose
was so much bigger than my fear that I'm
ready to tackle that and I just wanted
to share my story one of the things you
said in the Ted Talk that I never
thought about we get our driver's
license we take it for granted you said
for you your driver's license wasn't
just to drive it was also saying that
you could live yeah why because on your
driver's license when it said gender it
said f for female it's just that
affirmation right I mean like as as you
said it's the most basic thing that we
tend to forget I mean like trans people
just want to live our lives to feel
affirm and certainly as someone who was
born and raised in the Philippines
we didn't have access to to it to be
able to change name and gender marker
and legal documents so when I moved to
America it was my way to like oh here I
could be legally recognized as a woman
that I am and speaking of that your mom
was very supportive in that process and
she's in the Progressive green room
right now hanging out shout out to moms
what is it like though having that
support system behind you every single
step of the way
you know I I couldn't ask for a better
parent my mom who just truly loves me
this is a devout Catholic woman who
loves her trans daughter and for her to
be able you know she left the
Philippines we were separated for five
years when he got to the point that okay
I'm ready to finally move to America she
is the one that told me that here in
America you could be legal she
researched that policy of gender
recognition policy oh Mom she's also the
one that gave you the name Gina with two
e's she said as a way to stand out your
mom your dad too who's no longer with us
who was also very supportive but I
wonder what it was like for you because
in the Philippines they knew yeah but
you lived your life when you came here
just mortified oh my God I hope they
don't find out you're in the John Legend
video for number one back in the day you
you're living with this big secret you
tell a great story you're in a New York
Cab where you have this big moment but
yet it was a high for you because you'd
gotten a big deal but you felt so empty
inside why you know I've in the
Philippines trans people are culturally
visible right we're part of mainstream
culture yeah we're not politically
recognized there are no rights you know
for gender recognition policy but when
they moved to America it was the other
way around I was legally recognized as a
woman in my f but there was no cultural
visibility thus you know when I moved to
New York City in 2005
had to go stealth you know where my
mother would say it's stealth yeah and
you know in the book and Horace Barbie I
detailed sort of like I felt like now I
look back
why like the Spy genres because I felt
like I was a spy in the kindness exactly
for eight years biggest secret ever yeah
in that moment in in the book Because as
a fashion model
I entered this industry that is all
about the power of imagery but I was not
being seen every day of my life for
eight years it was this constant
um I was so visible right I was in
Congress of magazine billboards
but I was also consciously invisible
yeah at the same time so managing all
that for eight years took its doll the
the the title horse Barbie comes from
what your competitors would call you on
the pageant circuit uh in the
Philippines but I actually want to talk
about the visibility right because so
much has changed culturally in America
uh your your book is out you've got a
major publisher you've got a TED Talk
that went viral right people know you
um and yet you also describe the the
situation here in the U.S for Trans
people as nightmarish talk about that
dichotomy those two worlds I really felt
like I've been like living because I've
lived half of my life in the US I mean
half the life in the Philippines half
here in the US so it's just this
constant navigating the different
cultures
because what we have in the Philippines
and what you know of experienced the
Philippines now we know that visibility
is just one component in finding Equity
it should be all of that right the
equity access to the most basic rights
the visibility respectable
Nuance dignified uh visibility for Trans
people all of those things and I think
even in this moment that what we're
seeing right now the attacks and
particularly trans use the most
vulnerable in our in our country we need
to honor their lived experience I I want
to tell them that there is nothing wrong
with them keep living your life be who
you are as what I've detailed in my book
you know I you know you have to say on
page 243 and this is how we should enter
that trans Joy can never be fully
extinguished and that really is a
message that you're putting out I think
your book will help many people I think
you may be struggling who may be curious
who may be wondering and any Walk of
Life yes exactly right now educate
people I think there's something there's
something powerful with trans people
like we know who we are in the world
that tells us that doesn't give us space
we still choose to be who are there's
nothing more courageous than that and I
just want to honor that particularly
trans youth that are wanting to just
live their dreams I honor them of course
Barbie you have done that I've done that
stories are our resource and this is one
uh horse Barbies is the book Gina with
Sarah thank you very much for being here
uh it is on sale wherever you like to
buy your books there's the cover